seit über zehn jahren sind die meisten
osteuropäischen länder in der nato
obwohl moskau heftig dagegen protestiert
mittlerweile zeichnet sich auch eine
russische gegenstrategie ab die den raum
von kaliningrad bis syrien umfasst das
verhältnis zur türkei spielt dabei eine
wichtige rolle
heute in vechta kompakt
machtverschiebung im schwarzmeerraum die
ausgangssituation ist bekannt das
verhältnis zwischen dem kreml und der
nato ist stark belastet
dem von georgien angestrebten nato
beitritt hat moskau 2008 durch die
militärische intervention in südossetien
einen riegel vorgeschoben
mit der annexion der krim und dem von
moskau unterstützten krieg in dombach
wird auch ein eu und nato beitritt der
ukraine auf absehbare zeit verhindert
bisherige entwicklungen lassen daher auf
eine deutliche verschiebung der
politischen und militärischen
machtverhältnisse im osten und südosten
europas schließen
auf russischer seite ist dabei
anzuführen erstens militärische
aufrüstung auf der krim und verstärkung
der schwarzmeerflotte die halbinsel wird
seit 2014 als militärstützpunkt
ausgebaut mit den flug und schiff
abwehrraketen kann beinahe das gesamte
schwarze mehr kontrolliert werden
die schwarzmeerflotte wird verstärkt
insbesondere durch u-boote mit
raketensystemen mit der brücke von
kertsch kann russland außerdem die
zufahrt ins social mehr kontrollieren
zweitens die verstärkte kooperation
russlands mit der türkei der ankauf des
s400 flugabwehrsystem durch ankara zeigt
dass sich das verhältnis zu moskau
deutlich verbessert hat deshalb unter
sagte washington die lieferung seiner f
35 kampfflugzeugen und russland hat
prompt modernste kampfjets angeboten
und drittens die festigung der
russischen position in syrien
oskar ist dabei aus tattoos eine
leistungsfähige marinebasis zu machen
2009 10 wurde außerdem ein abkommen über
die wirtschaftliche nutzung des zivilen
buffons auf 49 jahre abgeschlossen
zusätzlich wurde ein
luftwaffenstützpunkt nahe der
mittelmeerküste eingerichtet seitens der
nato und der usa ist anzuführen erstens
der ausbau der us raketenabwehr in
europa 2016 ist in rumänien ein system
mit 24 raketen in betrieb gegangen
schon die ersten planungen 2011 führten
zu heftigen protesten moskaus nicht
zuletzt hat es damit den ausstieg aus
dem vertrag begründet eine zweite
raketenbasis in polen befindet sich in
der testphase
zweitens die sogenannte vorne präsenz
seit 2017 nzd nato im wechsel
militäreinheiten von bis zu 1400 mann zu
den baltischen mitgliedern nach polen
rumänien und bulgarien
das soll einerseits sind
sicherheitsgefühl vermitteln und
andererseits russland von militärischen
aktionen abhalten
außerdem kontrollieren nato-partner den
luftraum der baltischen staaten
und drittens verstärkte patrouillen
tätigkeit im schwarzen meer
seit 2010 besteht eine rotierende task
force der us marine kurs für das
schwarze meer in den letzten jahren
patroullieren auch vermehrte nato
marineverbände aber die anwesenheit von
schiffen der us-marine und anderer
nato-staaten ist durch die sogenannte
montreux erklärung stark eingeschränkt
demnach darf immer nur eine bestimmte
anzahl von schiffen für maximal 21 tage
vor ort
wie verhält sich europa wie die türkei
die eu beobachtet den aufbau des
russische militär potenzials im
schwarzmeerraum sehr aufmerksam als soft
power setzt brüssel dabei auf dialog
kooperation bei der
kriminalitätsbekämpfung und
zusammenarbeit bei der küstenwache und
grenzkontrolle die türkei verfolgt eine
eigenständige außen und
sicherheitspolitik ankara möchte nicht
als handlanger der usa oder der nato
gelte es beharrt auf dem montreux
dekoration und ist gegen zusätzliche
militärische aktivitäten im schwarzen
meer wie weiß ich die türkei durch den
ankauf des s400 systems
russland annähert bleibt offen sie ist
aber wegen ihres engagements in syrien
auf ein gutes verhältnis zu moskau
angewiesen
russland scheint mit seiner
stationierung politik und dem ausbau von
marine und raketen kapazitäten eine
gegenstrategie zur nato osterweiterung
zu verfolgen
schon 2016 verkündet die generalstabchef
gerasimov dass russland die effektive
kontrolle über das schwarze meer
übernommen habe und syrien bietet die
möglichkeit militärische kräfte
permanent im östlichen mittelmeer zu
stationieren und die position moskaus
auszubauen
ein gutes verhältnis zur türkei ist aber
nützlich weil dadurch auch spannungen
innerhalb der nato erzeugt werden können
ein ausblick derzeit zeichnet sich im
osten und südosten europas eine
machtverschiebung zugunsten moskau hat
russland demonstriert damit
geopolitische ansprüche unter definiert
seine zone des besonderen interesses
dadurch soll der einfluss des westens
zurückgedrängt oder zumindest der status
quo in der region erhalten werden
mit dem vorgehen in georgien in der
ukraine und in syrien wurde klargestellt
dass nötigen falls auch militärische
mittel zum einsatz kommen
damit dies gewissermaßen ein
geopolitisches parteien getreten
das deutet nicht auf eine militärische
eskalation hin vielmehr werden
strategische pflöcke eingeschlagen die
wollen doch länger halten können